european parliament opened its seat in
Strasburg to celebrate Europe day and
the ideas shaped by one of the e u--'s
founding fathers robert schumann
vice-president rhino violent said if any
country felt it could solve issues alone
they were wrong for that reason he said
he still intact ofna tiny window by
regulating heights mid mention i was
fishing in linden to summon sue coleman
anticipation conductance to force eat'em
this year's event the 24th was themed
united in diversity and abundance of
which was plainly on offer one high spot
was the no habitual public debate in
Parliament chamber more a
question-and-answer opportunity on well
pretty well anything by pretty well
anyone do you opt to develop a or some
in birth education and the solution to
today's many problems refugees and
extremism papas accident vardesh
Amarillo serum era don't go for full
Felicity decision large pants osmanli
options questions on suicide watch
economy Caracas Lebanon serramonte suit
knowledge on ceremony events continue
during the month throughout Europe
culminating in an open doors at the
Parliament in Brussels